one of the side effects of this pandemic
is a sharp drop in life-saving organ
transplants transplant centers across
the country have massively scaled back
as hospitals shift priorities to be able
to handle kovat 19 cases living donor
surgeries have largely shut down and
deceased donor transplants are happening
only when the case is urgent sadly that
means many organs are not going to good
use and as Allison Busch Nick explains
those on the waiting list
keep waiting at a distance John Dennis
waves to the love of his life
penny is living with dementia her
long-term care home has residents sick
with kovat 19 it's just too risky to
visit for both of them
John has idiopathic pulmonary fibrosis
and needs a double lung transplant
Cobin 19 can be a killer especially for
someone with lung disease to covet 19
get the hell of the way to my family and
John's the right guy for a fight
if they can see that on the camera an
avid adventurer he even competed in an
around-the-world sailing race he's now
in the fight of his life if all goes
well John would travel from Halifax to
the Toronto General Hospital for
transplant this is the largest
transplant program in the country and
one of the top in the world this is a
center of innovation and life-changing
surgeries with the Cova 19 wave coming
on March 13th the hospital announced it
had to scale back transplants heart
liver kidney pancreas and lung delayed
unless a patient is rapidly
deteriorating when we do a transplant we
put patients on anti-rejection pills and
that means really knocking down
their immune system and we're very
worried if we do that to patients and
then if they get Kovac they'll end up
with very very severe manifestations of
Kovac
that also means Kovac 19 patients and
transplant patients could end up in the
same I see you both needing ventilators
spreading the virus is a concern
Colvin seems to also infect the liver
and the kidney and the heart so so we're
we're very concerned about that
in early March Jim man finally got the
call that he's officially on the
transplant list
soon after that another call about the
delays Jim needs a double lung
transplant for severe and phase Emma the
Koba 19 is what scares me more than the
surgery they've told me if I if I got
that and my chance of survival I'm very
very you feel really let down and it
kind of breaks your heart because we had
that hope and then it's kind of like
it's on pausing nobody knows how long
this is gonna go on for so for Jim
outgoing fun-loving and always willing
to help a friend is inside protecting
himself while he waits every time the
phone rings still even though we know
it's closed I still have a little bit of
hope that's what it is and it's not just
in Toronto transplants are on hold or
reduced at centers across the country
leading doctors who refer patients to
worry this does have a huge impact on my
patients but all transplant patients in
general across Canada there's multiple
effects so there's patients right now
who are very unwell and getting sicker
quickly another devastating consequence
of that with programs across the country
scaled back so too is the procurement of
donor organs so essentially those organs
are not used they're lost to the system
which is really another tragedy due to
covert so it's very heartbreaking
actually hundreds of Canadians die every
year waiting for a transplant and now
Koba 19 is making that even tougher the
number of patients on the way
it is brewing and that will create a
backlog during the last month Toronto
general has performed more than 15
urgent transplants with safety
precautions in place and testing all
donor organs for kovat 19 all the
precautions and gained knowledge is
leading to renewed hope doctor whom are
says he's actively working on how to
increase the number of transplants
performed and is optimistic that can
start soon until then Jim and John are
staying safe and hopeful I know there's
there's a fix down the road
it's just hopefully it comes before I
can't belong anymore like this I know
it's it's getting worse I just hope I
can I can make it to draw it's all I ask
give me a chance
[Music]